how concerned are you that as ukraine
resists
russia will then use nuclear weapons
me personally i don't believe that
russia will use the nuclear weapon
the people who made these decisions
like
to live
want to live
and
if they started to use the weapons
nuclear weapons
it will be end
not just for this some soldier who is
coming this aggressions it will be end
it will be a
new nuclear war
and nobody know
who will be in life after this and these
people
uh it could be the end of the world you
mean yeah
and i i think these people too much
uh want to be in life
yeah to risk so much the first british
national who came over here to fight as
a volunteer has been killed he got
killed a guy called scott sibley um in
mikolayev what's your response to that
it's
big tragedy that this person is killed
and of course my
deeply condolence
to the relatives to the family
but in the same time
it's mean that
for the british people
our war
they
feel like a war
of your people of your feelings and you
understand
that it this is the war for the freedom
how long will this war last
i hope not
long i know i know maybe maybe
some people wanted that it will be
too long
i think the mostly ukrainians want that
it's
finished as soon as possible but i think
it will be up to the our victory
and i hope it will be
so we
win i'm sure about